one of the greatest Portland
Trailblazers of all time won his
championship in his beloved Houston with
the Rockets a dream team err etc etc
two-time Basketball Hall of Fame
inductee and Commissioner of the big
three Clyde Drexler good to see a clock
delighted to be here do I call you
commissioner you can call me Clyde
Commissioner Drexler honey that sound
how does that sound to you sounds great
it sounds great the big three is a
phenomenal league and I'm delighted to
be the new commissioner there you go so
cube asks you to be Commissioner Jeff
Kuantan it's ask you be commissioner
well what's the first thing you did as
commissioner well the first thing I did
was to figure out what what I need to do
okay with the startup League there are a
lot of things that's going on at all
times and these guys are tremendously
innovative Jeff Jeff continents and Ice
Cube they're there every day working in
the office like you and I and I you know
that's to me that was a motivator these
guys are really concerned about the
league the big three it's a passion
mm-hmm they live it they love it they
work it they breathe it and as a result
many players get to participate and
continue on with their dreams the fans
love it
every city we go to they're like rock
stars you got all these stars and and
legendary coaches guys like Julius
Erving George Gervin Gary Payton and
Rick berry and and then you got some of
these incredible players that everyone
knew from the NBA guys like Kenyon
Martin Al Harrington AI Allen Iverson I
mean Cuttino Mobley korma Getty the list
goes on and on there's just so many
stars in our league yeah and Cory
mcGarry's coach is gonna be joining us
later on Nancy Lieberman you're the old
you're the former coach right yeah
absolutely you you stepped up from power
to the to the front office and primacy
leverage to be here here in our number
two so let's talk about the Houston
Rockets right now which is where the big
three is going to start the season June
22nd it could possibly be right after a
parade in that town absolutely so my
question for you is what what do you
think is
keeps up D'Antoni at night before these
playoffs begin this weekend the pressure
depression when you've had the best
record in the regular season by far
you've been stellar offensively we know
you can score you proven you can defend
but you haven't done it well enough
through the years to win the title Chris
Paul has been great player perhaps the
best point guard of his generation but
he hasn't had a title to prove it he
hasn't even made a conference finals
exactly James Harden has been young MVP
caliber player the last four or five
years he needs a title to confirm it
Mike D'Antoni many 60 win teams in
Phoenix never a title to show that I'm
really good and so those three guys are
highly motivated and they're hungry for
a title as opposed to the Warriors are
the Cavaliers who have titles it's just
regular business playing in May and June
for them I think the Rockets have an
edge because they're hungrier because
they've not had it
I guess Harden how has he changed in the
last couple of years
well Claude James has change he's become
more of a leader he's always been a
phenomenal basketball player and and
that's undisputed but I think he's
matured as a player he's a little bit
older and that happens and James has
always been a great teammate if you're
open he'll pass you the ball he does
plays good defense he's become what is
running me Chris Paul I think they have
the best chemistry I've seen in a long
time
but I guess the the scuttlebutt one
would say is that when push comes to
shove second season comes as is now
arrived that the Rockets do not have
defensively certainly with the coach the
horses to take down anybody who matches
up with them and a half-court game what
do you say to that well they have to
prove that I think they've proven that
throughout the regular season because
teams have tried everything doubling
tripling James and Chris leaving other
guys open giving him taken away the
three-point shots given a mid range
they've got an answer for all of that
now the key is can you do it on demand
in the postseason
I think they can which is the team you
think they can give him the most fits
obviously is it Gore is it the Warriors
well what if it what if Curry's not
there the Warriors still they still have
a star-studded team the
there they have a cohesive unit there
well coach these guys know what to do
they get a lot of veterans on their team
guys who know their rows and they're
happy with their rows that's why they're
so good
Clyde Drexler here on the Rich Eisen
show I've got Damian Lillard coming up
next after you and I have a nice chat
here do you think he's taking the mantle
from you absolutely
III think Damien's wanted the best peer
points in the game he can score he can
pass he's a leader he shows up every
night he's embraced that role and I love
watching him play and super nice guys
why not then then why not them this year
well I think they were like in one or
two pieces you know if they can feel
those one or two voids on their team and
I don't want to call them out but I
think they're they've done extremely
well 49 wins and the regular season sure
that's good but but you know to most of
the champions are in the 50 60 win
categories are each so we are in the era
of the super team if you don't have it
you don't have a shot so you're
basically saying no no you're only as
good as you play they have they have
superstars that backcourt of Lillard and
McCullum are really good but the big
guys have got to come through the front
court is not exactly scaring anyone
mm-hmm Oh though Newark ik is playing
pretty well Clyde Drexler here on the
Rich Eisen show let's what was the dream
team practices like nobody ever you you
couldn't get in there right
the the magic Jordan scrimmages they
were phenomenal to watch what watch you
weren't you weren't at him well I was in
him but not really cuz I had a bad knee
okay and I was just trying to survive
the experience of playing in the
Olympics I needed surgery on my right
leg so I wasn't really trying to get in
any scraps but what happened magic and
Michael were talking and yucking it up
and and you know magic will get Michael
all hyped up and guess who's got a guard
him you with a bad right okay cut it out
just cut it out what is Magic saying to
Michael Jordan oh they're just having
fun great guys I know that but what
would he get jordan's go
you know trash-talking at the highest
level is really good i mean those guys
on each other skin like never before
highest level I mean that that's that's
like rare that I mean we're in a
different atmosphere with that at that
level exactly so what can you give me a
little bit of an example which I could
but I don't want to you know confidence
you know you don't wanna just like Fight
Club
absolutely you know it's what happens in
the gym stays in the gym but you know
when you get competitive guys of any any
sport together in your practice and even
though they're on the same team yeah
when they're practicing they're gonna go
hard but what bird was kind of like me
yeah and kind of a bad twitch in his
back and he was trying to survive the
experience as well and we're kind of
laid back what was Charles's role in
this whole thing oh I don't know if he
had one but he was talking somewhere
this ain't it this is always stuff that
I cannot believe actually did happen
we're also showing a shot of Laettner on
the screen right now are you guys
surprised it was him not shocked well
you know we if sometimes people ask what
was a criterion for making that team the
criterion change from from person to
person but I think the guys who were
involved was just trying to put together
the best team that they thought was the
best fit and so Shaq was probably the
most dominant player Laettner was
probably the best winner at that time in
college basketball right so you couldn't
go wrong and while we're on the subject
of college basketball you know I wanted
to ask you about this Clyde Drexler here
in the Rich Eisen show every year we see
at the ESPYs you know Jimmy V Jim
Valvano and then they will always show
the moment that he's running on the
court looking for someone a hug can't
believe that NC State just pulled off
the greatest upset of all time you were
on the opposite end of that what is that
like for you to relive that almost all
the time well you don't relive it
because that's one game out of like two
3,000 games that you played that was an
important game and of course you'd like
to win and so you're disappointed but
you got to understand from my standpoint
we you know we played hard were the best
team in college basketball North
Carolina State was a very good team
people don't realize they beat four or
five good teams before they beat us
exact same way coming from behind guys
had to miss free-throws and order for
them and even have a chance to win the
game and so I'll take that every time
really sure but give them credit they
were able to do it Jim Valvano if he
didn't win that game we would never know
who he was or his cancer research would
never be as great as it has been so
there's a reason why things happen rich
what was what was the first time you met
Hakeem first time I met him he came in
he was Hakeem right Aki iak he was Aki
man and you know the H is silent so he
probably said Hakeem but nobody really
heard no just a lot of ignorance on our
part basically and so he was the nicest
guy ever he came in from Nigeria and
coach Lewis guy Lewis who was our head
coach he was uh he was one of those
coaches who thought if you were a big
guy 610 or over he could teach you how
to play in the post and luckily Hakeem
went to that coach had he gone to a
guard oriented coach it might have been
a different story
think about it because even though he
was 610 there's probably 195 and he had
good legs cuz he played soccer but his
basketball skills you know we're not
there at that time when was the first
time he dunked a basketball remember
them all rich you know I dumped the
basketball probably in the ninth grade
and and I think I celebrated for like a
week it was just a regular dunk two-hand
windmill what you do it was a rub in
probably would have volleyball because
you couldn't palm it may be celebrated
then you know it's promising you know
wow I'm gonna continue to grow hopefully
and I know I'm gonna be able to do more
in the future so it was that realization
that if you practice and if you continue
to grow good things is gonna happen
yeah then Houston this year I had a
tournament win for the first time since
phi slamma jamma yeah it was good to see
it was good to see I know good for the
program good for the city yeah that kid
gray I think you play don't you think I
think he's a pro next level right I
think he's gonna play at the next level
III think he has a shot okay cuz on that
next level where everyone's big mmm
quick fast they're experienced and those
jobs are hard to get
if you were playing Clyde Drexler on the
Rich Eisen show if you were playing now
would you be one and done would you been
one and done in Houston oh that's hard
to say yeah I mean think about it when
we were coming out guys like Magic
Johnson
Isiah Thomas they were one in two and
done it happened James Worthy Michael
Jordan Hakeem and I we were three and
done but could we ago in a couple years
earlier I'm sure you sure I'm sure you
know cuz we were looking at your draft
beforehand the number of juniors and
seniors they were all right seven of the
top ten were seniors seniors Wow and
then three juniors well back then you
had to be exceptional to go early you
had to prove yourself because you
couldn't just come out of high school
and say I want to go you have to have
some stats to back it up and so the
scouts were more concerned with what
have you done what are your credentials
now a lot of it is based on potential I
like to take a break spend a little bit
more time with you talk some big three
basketball with you in LeBron your two
cents on what LeBrons doing right now
and whether you think he's the MVP I
haven't seen harden up close as you have
yeah that's what we call a tease here a
claw Drexler the big three commissioner
live here on the Rich Eisen show Damian
Lillard who's as I said trying to take
this man's mantle as one of the greatest
Portland Trailblazers of all time he'll
be joining us at the top of our to here
on the Rich Eisen show
our poll question today is brought to
you by Farmers Insurance the road ahead
is bound to take some unexpected turns
farmers insurance can help you
understand your coverage options with
our practical knowledge gained from more
than 90 years of experience we know a
thing or two because we've seen a thing
or two find an agent of farmers calm ask
the poll question of a Clyde Drexler
Basketball Hall of Famer two times over
in big three Commissioner Chris Brockman
Clyde which three or four seed in the
NBA Playoffs has the best chance to win
the title Sixers Cavs Blazers Thunder
I'm gonna go I'm gonna go on the bran
theory his his record is impeccable I
think they're gonna be the best fourth
seed ever so you like what what what do
you think about what he has been able to
do Clyde I well when you were 33 put I
guess put yourself where you were
feeling and I don't even know if you
could you say you had as much mileage on
you as LeBron has on him right now well
well how many eight NBA Finals I think I
had only gone in like four three or four
mm-hmm but but you know the fact that he
does it every year he stays healthy the
guys probably I have so much respect for
him he's the greatest player of his
generation and it doesn't get enough
credit in my opinion he's a consummate
team player if you're open he'll pass it
even though you know he commands the
ball but he's so good you got to give
him the ball I love him I think LeBron
is uh you know been so good for the game
of basketball to sport and he's been a
great icon for the sport when did you
first meet him I think his rookie year
just incredible body incredible game and
the fact that he was so ahead of the
game mentally for his age well you know
he's got a big decision coming up and of
some of the more wild rumors is that he
would go to Houston what do you think
about that possibility well with Paul
and James Harden and yeah LeBron it's
kind of a tantamount to what the
Warriors did and Steph Curry klay
Thompson stat you would we justice it
looked again Damian Lillard coming up
he's as talented as they possibly can
come he take
time right at the Lillard time whatever
you want to call it it's happen it
happens in the fourth quarter he takes
games over he has that ability but youi
said he's a couple of pieces shy because
he's got it he's got a super team in in
Golden State and and daryl morey the
general manager in Houston is flat out
admitted that he it's an arms race is
basically what he's called him well he
called it an arms race which is a
brilliant statement but it's always been
a race about who can get the most talent
and it's been that way for many years
this is not the first year that that's
happened you think about the old Celtics
and the old Laker teams we had four or
five Hall of Famers on the same team but
they were able to draft most of them
right yeah I guess acquire acquired
koryu right right Michael Thompson
McAdoo and the Celtics acquired guys
like Dennis Johnson Robert Parish but
for the most part if you can get a bunch
of guys who are really talented planning
their prime together you're gonna have a
super team and those are traditionally
the teams that have won the championship
so do you think that's a possibility
knowing this team knowing the guys on it
knowing the coach know in the system if
LeBron raised his sand and I don't know
why he would want to leave the Eastern
Conference but if he said you know what
I want to win a ring I want to win one
with Chris Paul do you think it would
work I think any team that got LeBron
James would be bit much better I mean he
could go to Portland and make them a
contender he goes to Houston they become
the super team favorite every year and
so LeBron is a difference maker and it's
hard to you know if the Lakers got him
they'd be a contender so it doesn't
matter wherever he the King goes they're
gonna be really good if you were
Commissioner of the NBA what would be
what would you do Clark and in terms of
LeBron no no please you two made it make
what you say you're still trying to
figure out the big three what you're
gonna do oh no the big three is awesome
it's a machine right you got a great
think tank we got a me trash she's
traveling of our board yeah you got time
to cube continents I mean all these guys
are phenomenal right
phenomenal think-tank and so when when
you see the draft yesterday how
that go did you did you read off some of
the names yourself I did in the draft
elevated the big three
I mean competition these guys are every
team now the stack there are no yummy
bears I mean when you play every week
you're going to play a tough team there
are no yummy bears no yummy bears yeah I
could see the number one the number one
picked last night Andre Owens guard
Birdman is in this that's gonna be a lot
of fun he's a great addition he's on
power right now he was chosen fourth
overall Quentin Richardson q into the
mix absolutely he was a second-round
pick yeah this is great
enjoy being the commissioner it's been a
lot of fun we got a lot of work to do
but our fans are are looking forward to
the second season yes as we are and our
players it's you know the first season
was a banner year and the second second
season everyone now knows what to expect
they're getting more familiar with the
names of the team there are only eight
teams and we only play for ten weeks in
the summer right and so guys look
forward to it you don't want to miss it
Judis June 22nd in Houston absolutely
it's gonna be the first spot and you
check it out online to go see when
they're gonna be coming through to a
spot near you and get your tickets I
went with my kids last year it was great
thank you really good you of course come
on that was fantastic so Dez Bryan has
been released
he has are you a what what's your what's
your NFL team Klug the texans Texas
deshaun Watson have you have you met
that young man man and he goes to a lot
of Rockets games and he's a stud we got
to get him healthy
got to get JJ healthy right and let me
tell you something it could be on right
so your your Texan guy but the the news
out of Dallas Dez Bryant has been
released and according to the reports
they didn't even offer him a haircut huh
yeah Ian Rapoport saying did not offer a
pay cut simply released him no post June
1st designation clean star for Dallas
and Dez darn
Wow that is big news I didn't I did not
see that one coming also reported as he
was leaving the building said I'll see
these guys twice this year the Giants
would they really put him on the other
side of Odell Beckham Eagles have no cap
space so it's either Washington or the
Giants Washington
that would be interesting how about that
well that would be really something hey
Clyde congrats again on being named the
Commissioner of the big three there
you're you're awesome and I'm a big fan
of yours and I appreciate you coming in
thank you rich it's a pleasure to be on
your show thank you and I wish you
continued success thank you the Rich
Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience